did people curse in the real deadwood
like on hbo's deadwood how did the movie
get made 13 years after the show ended
how did the actors handle constant
rewrites keep watching for all the dirty
details
david milch the maestro behind deadwood
came to hbo well into a storied career
he began writing for hill street blues
in 1982 beginning a two-decade run of
bringing his dense literary style to
crime and legal dramas his most
successful endeavor to that point was
co-creating the show nypd blue with
steven bochko by the early 2000s he was
ready to create a new show using law
enforcement as a window into the way a
community is formed but the original
inspiration was not the time or place
you'd think in a 2006 interview with
american heritage milch said my initial
feeling was that i'd set it in ancient
rome the time of the emperor nero but
hbo already had the series roam in
production which they felt covered too
much of the same ground so they asked
milch if he could explore the same
themes of order forming from chaos in a
different historical setting milch
realized that the city of deadwood which
circa 1876 was a lawless mining camp in
native american territory was exactly
the setting he needed
one of the most striking things about
deadwood is its unabashed vulgarity
milch didn't specifically set out to
dispel the genteel myths of american
western movies but hbo gave him full
freedom to use as much violence nudity
and foul language as he needed to depict
his vision of the west as accurately as
possible
welcome to deadwood the language
specifically became the most talked
about aspect of deadwood when it
premiered causing most viewers to
immediately wonder did they really curse
like that in the real deadwood speaking
with npr the curator of deadwood's adams
museum admitted the short answer is yes
deadwood was a very profane place there
is ample evidence that all the curse
words used on deadwood existed at the
time the show is set scholar and
dictionary editor jesse scheidlauer told
new york magazine the evidence that we
have is that they were using more
religious blasphemy than the sexual
insults which are popular today but
instead of using antiquated terms like
gold darn and tarnation miltenko went
with language that would be as shocking
to modern audiences as the citizenry
intended
if you're a fan of deadwood you might
think the first roll cass was one of the
more central prominent characters on the
show who will deliver the crudely
eloquent monologues of al swearingen who
will embody the simmering rage of seth
bullock or the anxious gentility of alma
garrett but a chance encounter in 2002
led to a small role being the first
official casting jewell the sweet
disabled cleaning woman at the gem
saloon as actress jerry jewell told
yahoo entertainment i was at horton and
converse drugstore in santa monica
standing in line this man turned around
and he said oh my god are you jerry
jewell it was none other than future
deadwood creator david milch who
recognized jewell as cousin jerry on the
facts of life a role which broke ground
as the first recurring role for an actor
with cerebral palsy he promptly asked
her to be on the show and after one more
meeting the first member of his
sprawling ensemble was cast
despite a main cast of well over a dozen
and hundreds of recurring guest stars
bit parts and extras no actor boosted
their reputation more during the course
of deadwood than ian mcshane as l
swearingen the owner operator of the gem
saloon mcshane was central to the
labyrinthian plot of the show but
surprisingly the role wasn't originally
written with mcshane in mind david milch
wrote the role for ed o'neal best known
as al bundy on married with children
according to o'neill in an interview
with eric hedegaard david milch was so
certain on casting decisions that he
assured him you're going to be my
swearingen milch was convinced that
o'neal had the dramatic chops necessary
to overcome his reputation as a
recognizable comedy star unfortunately
hbo hadn't been consulted at all on the
decision at that point the network
wanted to cast someone as relatively
unknown as the rest of the cast and
suggested mcshane as milch told cni
magazine the minute mcshane walked in he
just took ownership of the role in my
imagination
the most recognizable deadwood cast
member is almost certainly keith
carradine known for dozens of western
roles he was so well prepared to play
wild bill in deadwood that he brought
his own wig custom made for him during
production of walter hill's wild bill
speaking with the av club carradine says
he received a call from walter hill now
set to direct the pilot of deadwood who
asked him what his hair looked like i
said well it's short walter but i still
got that wig reception of his
performance was so positive that hbo
initially pushed back on the character's
planned death in the fourth episode of
the show matching the timeline of the
real wild bill's infamous shooting
during a hand of poker carradine
recalled his conversation with milch at
the time to yahoo entertainment milch
said the good news is they love the show
the bad news is they don't want me to
kill hickok despite the network's note
getting his hopes up for a longer run
milch won the battle and stuck to the
original plan the character's presence
aided by carradine's pitch perfect
performance reverberated throughout the
rest of the show's run
praised for its dialogue plotting and
depth the success of deadwood begins and
ends with the writing
could you have been born richardson
and not egg hatched as i've always
assumed
and while there was a large team of
writers on the show nearly every script
was heavily rewritten by showrunner
david milch to better fit the rhythm of
the language he heard in his mind
sometimes on the spot it wasn't just the
writers that had to swallow their pride
actors needed to adjust to the demanding
task of learning several new pages of
dialogue on the spot actor brad doreth
who played fan favorite doc cochran
recalled a particularly infuriating
incident one time he came up to me and
said you see this line and he gave me
four pages i'm replacing this line with
this and it was a four page monologue
well before game of thrones gained
notoriety for killing off main
characters deadwood by the virtue of its
setting and commitment to authenticity
was the best example of a show willing
to kill off major characters without
warning it was simply a reality of the
west and the particular power struggles
that came with being a lawless frontier
mining camp viewers unfamiliar with
history were likely shocked when wild
bill hickok was shot and killed in just
the fourth episode of season one plenty
of characters would succumb to illness
stabbings gun fights and more over
deadwood's three seasons and feature
length movie
run for your
life
speaking with inside pulse during the
filming of season two jim beaver shared
the anxiety that he felt over the
potential fate of his character
pure-hearted prospector ellsworth
everybody on deadwood is worried they're
going to end up pig chow well maybe not
everybody but i think the warriors
outnumber the non-warriors ellsworth was
killed by an assassin at the end of
season three
one of the most memorable moments in all
of deadwood is the season three fight
between dan doherty played by w earl
brown and villainous henchman captain
turner milt wanted the fight to be
completely realistic and avoid western
cliches or as brown recounted to slash
film no cowboys flying through plate
glass
so the actors and crew found themselves
coordinating a bare hand all-out brawl
in the mud of the thoroughfare with no
clue how to end it fate intervened at a
poker game brown was playing with alison
chains guitarist jerry cantrell
apparently his brother dave cantrell had
once been badly losing a bar fight when
in desperation he tried to push the guy
off of him he felt his finger hit soft
tissue and knew without seeing it that
it was an eyeball and so the makers of
deadwood found their way to have doherty
seemingly about to lose his life turn
the tables by clawing out turner's eye
in a stroke of luck and by far the most
intense visual of the show was born
beyond well-known old west heroes like
wild bill and calamity jane many
characters in deadwood were based on
real citizens of the historical city of
deadwood central characters like al
swearingen sal starr and seth bullock
were based on real people although many
characters had slightly different fates
than their real life counterparts the
show's legacy has driven tourism to the
real deadwood to such a degree that
there are many specific travel packages
designed around the show and movie
visitors can experience the deadwood
heroes and villains tour among others
you can even get a guided walking tour
from the town's first marshal or at
least a re-enactor playing the part of
khan stapleton who was also a character
in deadwood while they welcome visitors
the city's official website does have an
entire section of its website about
differences between the hbo show and
real life
in interviews time and time again the
cast recall their time on deadwood as
head above all the rest speaking with
the av club w earl brown recalled
something a fellow actor once told it he
said i don't really care about money
fame and that stuff what i want to do is
something that has an impact and
deadwood was that for me i think it was
for everyone involved something really
really special keith carradine remarked
to the av club as well that it wasn't
just the role of wild bill hickok that
attracted him to the park but the mad
genius behind deadwood that made it more
memorable i mean what a role to have the
chance to play but especially as written
by milch it was extraordinary stuff he
wrote this kind of american shakespeare
reflecting on returning to her role as
calamity jane for deadwood the movie
robin weiger told slash film we were
getting incredible words to say and i
knew that i was with an exceptional cast
that everybody i got to partner with in
scenes was humbling
wonderful after a slow motion death in
2006 when hbo and david milch debated
about production schedules costs and the
length of a potential season 4 for so
long that the cast contracts expired
there were rumors of everyone reuniting
for one or possibly two wrap-up movies
but each time the plans didn't come to
fruition it sank the sprawling cast
spirits further until it seemed all hope
was lost asked by vulture if he ever
thought the movie would really happen
the famously verbose ian mcshane replied
with a kurt no even w earl brown who for
years maintained a handwritten list of
every main cast member's commitments for
several years just in case lost the
faith at some point in 2019 he told
slash film i gave up beating the dead
horse after a few years finally on the
strength of deadwood's strong dvd sales
and streaming legacy milton hbo struck a
deal deadwood the movie premiered on hbo
in 2019 garnering high praise from both
critics and fans what a grand surprise
after such a piece of time
in 2015 david milch received a diagnosis
of alzheimer's just months later he
finally reached an agreement with hbo to
write a script for deadwood the movie
and began a four-year process of
wrapping up the story his usual mad rush
of reassembling sets and scenes on a
whim and last minute rewrites were
tempered by the symptoms of the disease
he relied more on the director and other
producers to run things on set and stuck
to the script but that script was still
pure milch magic and writing has proved
to be milch's best weapon to hold on to
his mind in the face of the disease's
progression speaking with vulture his
wife rita described it with an analogy
perfect for the legendary tv creator who
wrote an ensemble cast's voices like a
symphony conductor i compare it to a
musician who can still play and has
access to the memory of how to do that
and is still able to exercise his talent
the brain is david's most exercised
muscle
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]